whales are the biggest animals of all
time heavier than elephants woolly
mammoths and even dinosaurs but they
weren't always the titans of the sea
let's rewind the clock around 50 million
years no you won't find any whales here
you have to go ashore meets pakicetus
the very first whale life on earth spent
millions of years clawing its way out of
the oceans but whales took all that
effort and threw it out the window from
fifty to forty million years ago they
traded in their forelegs for flippers in
fact some whales today still have
leftover bones of hind legs once
submerged their weight under gravity no
longer mattered so they could
theoretically grow to enormous
proportions and they did today a blue
whale is 10,000 times more massive than
the pakicetus was but this
transformation wasn't as gradual as you
might think in fact over the next 37
million years or so whales grew
increasingly diverse but their size
remains small for example one of the
first whales with baleen instead of
teeth was only 18 feet long making them
easy prey for predators like giant
sharks it wasn't until around 3 million
years ago that an ice age tipped the
scales in the Wells favour
ocean temperatures and currents shifted
sparking concentrated swarms of plankton
and plankton seeking krill it was an
all-you-can-eat buffet for the baleen
whales who grew larger as a result and
the larger they became the farther they
could travel in search of more food to
grow even more
you can probably see where this is going
three million years later hunt backs for
example have one of the longest
migrations of any mammal on earth
traveling over five thousand miles each
year as a result modern whales are the
largest they've ever been in history
take the biggest of the bunch the blue
whale
it weighs more than a Boeing 757 has a
belly button the size of a plate and its
network of blood vessels if you laid
them out in a line could stretch from
Pluto to the Sun and back over two and a
half times in fact the largest blue
whales are so huge that scientists think
they may have hit a physical limit when
they open their wide mouths to feed they
engulf enough water to fill a large
living room so it can take as long as
ten seconds to close them again
scientists estimate once a whale is 110
feet long it can't close its mouth fast
enough before prey escapes so it's
possible we're living amongst the
largest animal that will ever exist
lucky for us they mostly just eat krill
this was made in large part thanks to
Nick Penson and the information in his
new book spying on whales